tennis and most people who come to LA
have had a humbling job or two or three
and la is an easy place to feel humble
too huh have you ever been in this
situation and how did you take care of
yourself because there is a mindset that
you can adopt to survive these humbling
jobs i am in that situation right now as
a matter of fact um and I first of all I
do not talk about my day job because I
have absolutely nothing positive to say
it's just no point it's not a good story
it's no fun it's just angry you don't
mean so uh frankly I've been meditating
I've been edits really it's one of those
jobs you're like wow like it's like I do
things I'm not proud of and um and and
at the same time you know there's plenty
people telling me that it's fine your
integrity is fine at the end of the day
I need to keep the rent paid I need to
keep food on the table I am looking
tirelessly for other work that's the
first thing like I walk out of that job
every day seriously doubting my
self-worth and I make the rest of the
day my challenge to do something that
makes me worthy that makes that you know
mean and and and looking for other work
as a part of that quantum theory it
keeps me focused because I just can't
afford not to get this moving up I
absolutely cannot and apart from that uh
you know I'm constantly helping other
people in the industry of the fullest
dummy part of the reason why I write
articles for film car I just because
I've had a lot of experiences and I know
that the wreck filmmaker is looking for
help and I can make it a little easier
and and that makes me feel good
you